j'ai toujours été assez combative et le
judo me permet de m'exprimer de me
libérer
c'est un sport comme les autres mon
flanc en plus on peut un peu défendre je
travaille huit heures par jour enquête
sur l'incident tout sur une chaise toute
la journée ça nous porte
certains événements quoi un moyen de
défense
ah bon ah oui parce que dans la rue
maintenant pour faire à sortir
qu'est ce que vous avez apporté juno
beaucoup de détente parce que j'ai un
travail qui est plutôt rare voir si on
veut dire est qu ancien au club
ou alors ici c'est formidable c'est une
détente complète
j'étais un peu gaffeur pourquoi pas
m
elles sont de plus en plus nombreuses à
s'intéresser au judo trente mille
licenciés pour 310 bill pratiquants soit
à peu près une femme pour dix judokas le
judo féminin français est en plein essor
progression étonnante il se situe même à
la première place en europe
en ce qui concerne l'importance de ses
effectifs devant l'allemagne fédérale et
la grande bretagne jusqu'à présent en
france pas de compétition officielle
pour les dames par kroos n existe déjà
en anglais
r en allemagne de l'est en italie en
suisse et en hollande
le passage des grades se fait selon des
critères exclusivement technique
contrôlée par le comité national des
grades de la fédération française de
judo
actuellement il ya en france environ 250
ceintures noires dont 8 3e dan
cette année un tournoi expérimental a
été organisé pour la première fois au
stade de coubertin
il a révélé un niveau d'ensemble déjà
excellent 8 dan à eux deux l-3 lui 5
ils sont mari et femme au dojo national
de faerie monsieur et madame le vannier
s'occupe de l'entraînement des meilleurs
éléments féminins assez peu de
différences entre le judo féminin et le
judo masculin
mais pas question bien sûr faut une
ceinture noire de battre un ceinture
noire différence intervient sur point de
vue de de la force physique
alors là évidemment la différence
intervient c'est un peu comme les autres
sports si vous voulez l'athlétisme ou
autre le style réseau même peut-être
même on a défini qui sont pétés sa plus
belle au point de vue
exécution mouvement mais elle reste tout
même moins efficace penser que les
femmes sont peu disposés pour
particulièrement pour le judo judo dans
son expression ses principes de l'art
souple alors je crois que dans son
esprit même il est adapté à la femme il
devrait pouvoir permettre à la femme de
s'exprimer je crois que c'est du lot et
pratique est véritablement dans le sang
ce qui doit être fait il n'y a pas de
raisons je crois que la fin d'un grand
avenir
je pense également d'ailleurs j'ai fait
des compétitions j'en ai fait même en
ligne ce qui est tout de même difficile
et j'étais très contente très heureuse
de pouvoir m'exprimer parce qu'il arrive
à un moment donné où on a une certaine
forme une certaine classe un certain
rythme et je pense que c'est nécessaire
de faire compétition pour voir où en
sont les progrès justement c'est un peu
indispensable un peu indispensable quand
on a envie de faire du grand judo il
faut terminer par la compétition
culinaire
absolument le judo sport féminin à part
entière c'est une perspective assez
proches les 1er et 2 décembre à ger
l'équipe de france féminine fera ses
grands débuts en compétition
internationale
on pourra alors mieux situer la valeur
du judo féminin français